I'm still looking for the New Mutants
I'm assuming we're all the additional
photography reshoots of that movie are
they done or is it still becomes Telecom
so doc do you know what you got you're
doing it is you guys have had at this
studio tremendous success with r-rated
movies his New Mutants the kind of movie
that could go our or this is going to be
a horn pg-13 it's a kind of it could go
our or it could be a heartbeat you 13 it
is like we were saying us like I was
saying before in terms of subgenres with
the genre it is obviously as it was
trailer or teased a horror phone and
most war films these days are r-rated
but it stars a very young cast so we'll
say it really is what the movie wants to
be the studio is open to their rating I
was going to say because recently
there's been a lot of horror rated
horror movies that have come out that it
performed tremendous at the box office
Halloween's about to open to huge
numbers so you can see there's you know
there you can I could see both sides on
this one yeah sure you know you
traditionally superhero movies would be
to 13 other than Logan and and the
diplom of these and traditionally horror
films are r-rated most recently so we'll
see where this one Falls it certainly is
a very edgy scary movie it does feel
like the at least at Fox they're kind of
letting the movie what the movie
requires dictate rating rather than what
it was even a decade ago where it was
kind of conventional wisdom superseded
and dictated what the rating was now
it's much more a function of where do
you think what do you think you need to
tell the story does that rating become
an important element or not